with this fireside chat and Nico is
still here but he asked me earlier so
where's the fireplace that said the
fires over here yeah so I have the
pleasure of introducing Simon Rothman
who is by any measure one of the if not
the leading VC person in the platform
marketplace space I got to I met Simon
at a conference that Greylock had I want
to say four years ago maybe on platforms
and a common acquaintance invited me
Andre hog you who's at Boston University
and it was fascinating kind of meeting
all these startups on marketplaces and
there was a room probably twice the size
and it was three times as packed and and
in fact out of that came a fun
relationship I I agreed to meet with
some regularity with this startup that
is now called roof stock Gary and and
just seeing the proliferation was really
fascinating and I don't have to say this
here because I know there are people
here in the room involved in in so many
platforms so we agreed to do this little
fireside chat and I prepared oops and I
prepared a bunch of questions so I'll
just run through what comes up and
please feel free to add questions from
the audience and and let me just start
with something very basic and
definitional since we're academics and
we love definitions so you know I often
wonder about what defines a platform for
an investor like when you're looking at
these ideas and you have to put them oh
yeah I'm putting this in the platform
bucket how do you think about that so
I'll use platforms networks and
marketplaces interchangeably so
it's interesting I when I invest in
companies for a moment there was a time
where everyone wanted to invest in
marketplaces so everything you saw was
kind of classified as a marketplace even
though they're not and there's one right
now that I think is largely viewed as a
marketplace that I would not technically
so that might be good study but my
definition of a marketplace is where the
assets of production right is owned by
the someone else not by the platform
itself and the employees who provide
that product service so for example if
you look at say uber or Airbnb right the
individuals the supply side owns the
vehicle or owns the home so there's no
balance sheet for the company and the
people that provided the house and the
drivers are not employed directly at
least not yet I know there's a b5 going
on right now but at the current moment
not employed and so for me the
definition of our marketplace would be
no balance sheet you don't own assets
nor do you own kind of production
employment and the last piece is the
function you have is to match supply and
demand as your primary function and
create the trust necessary to close that
transaction that's it that's all you
know that it's a big thing but it
actually is a software thing and so
physical assets and people are not the
example I'd give you so obviously Airbnb
and uber and left it fit what my
definition of a platform would be the
one right now that I think it's
miscategorized routinely and I'm an
investor in it personally manifested
years ago slime the scooters and I hear
it all the time and especially since my
market place got like wow that's a great
market place it's growing really fast my
answer is yes it's growing really fast
it's a service business they owned the
scooters they serviced they maintained
there's some exceptions where they're
trying to get the community birders is
they're calling from bird where they'd
actually have a distributed labor force
that actually maintains them but that
let's be clear if you own billions of
dollars of scooters and scooters is the
service that your business is in you
a service company not an actual
marketplace and I think the majority of
investors the majority of people my my
tech world would disagree with that but
that's I think if I were going to find a
marginal line that's the marginal line
okay that's actually quite interesting
because my next question and this it
almost answers it was going to be when
we think about platforms a lot of people
don't think about supermarkets right but
if your supermarkets they have shelf
spaces and on the shelves or products of
other retailer basically wholesalers
right which is you know a form of a
platform so so I wonder you know is
there this line where is this platform
me enough for a marketplace enough and I
think your answer by using the lime
example is a great one bird or any one
of these because they basically it's the
ownership of the assets one other thing
if I can so so yeah unless if if the
grocery store were consigning the goods
I think you'd have a case of saying it's
approaching a platform right but here's
the thing when you look at investing for
platforms it's the platform itself from
these very binary there's no ambiguity
to me if it's a platform or not platform
but where there is a continuum then this
is something I think is not really well
understood the continuum is of the
strength of the network effects network
effects are not binary so if you take
the components the variables there is
how unique is a product or service how
fragment is a supply base how fragment
is the demand base and how local
regional national or global is the
distribution the closer it is to unique
product with an extremely fragmented
supply base extremely fragmented demand
base and a global to national scope the
stronger the network effects the
opposite would be the weaker the network
effects and that for me I think is the
most fascinating part of marketplaces as
they look at them most people the
outside marketplace high margins high
growth low capital it's not really the
same they're just not equal and when I
look at them I will in
only kind of judge your score how strong
the potential network dynamic is okay
I'm gonna turn and this is related to
the network effects for those of you who
haven't checked out
Simon's webpage I urge you to because he
wrote a lot and writes a lot and it's
very eloquent and very thoughtful and I
spent some time reading some of the
things that Simon wrote and you the
counter went up by one more okay and
from three to four my family and Steve
and so in April 2016 you wrote an
interesting piece titled why over one
and and I'm wondering if you still
believe obrah has I mean we all know
that they're growing and growing and
servicing globally but you look at the
balance sheet and things are not that
rosy and and in particular you know
competition is not going away we you
know lift is still around in Asia we
have DD and grabbed and you know all
these things so I'm wondering now three
years later what your thoughts are and
how you might relate that to the network
effects so let me let me break it up in
two things one why I believe they won
and and we can talk about what did they
went right is it a big prize there's the
size the price small so and I can even
talk about the dynamics how we got there
because it's a really really interesting
case study that hasn't been written that
I think is pretty fascinating but here's
what I wrote I wrote about uber strategy
their strategy was not to view capital
as financial it's the view capital
strategic they weaponized money and no
one had done this to this scale and I'd
argue anywhere near as effectively they
took what at the time was nine billion
in equity I think it ended up being I
know 1215 billion
they took capital and what they did is
they bought a network so let me be clear
in the article I lay it out where if CAC
is less than LTV caki customer
acquisition cost is less than lifetime
value you're trying to buy you're trying
to buy a sense of scale and in size
that's artificial because it's you know
you're spending more for users and their
worth if you're if you're CAC is less
than not greater than LTV you're buying
speed you're going fast you're growing
but if your aggregate CAC acquisition
cost is less than the aggregate network
value now you're buying a network you no
longer look at what one customers worth
what is it worth it and they bought a
hundred billion dollar network and spent
at the time nine billion which is a
smart deal their competitors were
looking at a user and saying this users
worth $50 I'm gonna spend $45 and
they're saying this network is worth a
hundred billion I'm gonna spend 19
billion dollars buying it and if I have
to spend five thousand for the user I'll
spend five thousand for the user and it
was amazing to watch that happen and
everyone and I was talking to was
shocked and they thought they were
financially you know just not smart and
they're they weren't very prudent and I
just thought everyone is missing the
point which is why I wrote the article
if you fast forward now and you look at
the market you have lyft has roughly a
quarter to third market share depending
on what data you look at in the US only
let me just not ever sit yeah
uber has the remaining three quarter
two-thirds three-quarters in the US and
it's a roughly similar split and they're
on one end or the other end of that
split in every market so there's a
dominant player and a second player the
real question that not been asked is why
is that true if you look at all other
platforms through history before and
after Airbnb who's the number to Airbnb
player would have material share the RB
oh really
not really who's the Airbnb of Europe
who's a rbb of Middle East
who's the air bebe of Asia Airbnb is the
Airbnb of all those areas right you look
at eBay in its prime you look at
Craigslist in its prime you you go
through one after another of
marketplaces and you will do it you will
not find a duopoly and any of them you
won't and the reason to evolve that way
is lyft and uber figured out how to get
liquidity at the same
time and it was a foot race for Cher and
it had week network effects they had
local network effects for commodity
service and they had the PlayBook in
hand and then it was just an arms race
who can raise more money who could move
faster who's willing to break more glass
in order to win market share and then
when it's settled all the dust settled
the shares were the shares it doesn't
shift much and it's hardened right and
so I think the formation period for
ride-sharing is unlike any other space
I've seen interesting the outcome is
different because of that if looper had
not copied left and I'm in personally a
full disclosure I'm a person Buster who
left if they hadn't copied them lyft
would actually be a monopoly here and
maybe everywhere they copied them
validated the model commoditize the
model by making it viable it turned it
into literally commodity you put money
and you buy the network and that is what
changes the dynamics the industry you
know it this brings me to a second
question that's related if I get out of
my list here I could show you the corner
down here ok we're left writing show
everybody uber and lyft are always right
next to each other because you know
especially for trips above the ten
fifteen dollar range within 30 seconds
I'm gonna check both of them now maybe
it's cuz an economist maybe because I'm
Jewish I don't know the point is I do
price comparison all the time right you
went there yeah I went there of course
so now I am older than from that
generation and so I'm kind of wondering
when we think of network effects how
much of it is at the platform versus the
market level in in your mind because in
essence if there is a certain service
let's say ride-sharing and and I love
the Airbnb example cuz you're right it
is very different but let's say the you
know rent a sofa rent a room rent a home
arena this market now people are more
comfortable with it so that the network
is people are looking for the stuff
people have the assets to put them on
the sellers and then really it makes
competition between platforms somewhat
easier because the network effect might
be at the market and not at the platform
and I'm wondering whether that is the
reality or no the uber lyft example
really is an outlier because of some
quirks I I don't know for sure I can
tell you my strong belief is that the
uber lyft model is a complete outlier
you look at it marketplaces structurally
become dominance that's part of their
attractiveness right and the reason
there is I mean you guys everyone in the
room if you're in this room you
understand what network effects mean
network effects get stronger as you get
bigger and what's interesting is that
almost every other business model you
can name gets weaker as it gets bigger
it slows it's more expensive everything
gets weaker except for network effects
which is part of the reason they're
really hard to kill right I mean look at
Microsoft I mean even think about
Microsoft it created a network effect
decades ago it had missed multiple
platform shifts it missed mobile it
missed the internet like holy crap how
many companies can miss multiple
platform shifts and now let me survive
it's on pace to be trillion-dollar
company its network dynamic is
un-frickin'-believable competitive
products the Google suite is as good as
a Microsoft Office suite it's fantastic
the network dynamic of it works when I
have it I use it because I know the
other person they're receiving and can
open it and can edit it it's and it's a
shitty product it's not outstanding I
think you'd be generous to call it
mediocre it's fine
not collaborative in an error that it
should be collaborative which I still
think they're missing also I mean it's
it's unbelievably powerful and that's
part of the beauty of it but I think
they anomaly is this multihoming only
exists if you believe that you can share
that that network dynamics don't work
and like I said I think the legacy of
how it got here
it's on the weekend of network effects
it figured it out in the same
those things are just really really
uncommon and I will be you know a little
bit more direct if one of the two
companies had lesson 12-month Head Start
if uber had figured our number
uber was was the bro business me kind of
the black car business and it copied
lyft there were the other way around and
they figured it out and they had a year
to go without being a chase by lift it
would be a monopoly an absolute monopoly
it would be right and so it's a really
weird kind of twist of fate that you
even have a multi-home you don't even
even have a choice I don't think that's
common mm-hmm okay nor do I think it
will be common most most marketplace no
that that sounds quite sensible so you
know as I was reading through how Luber
one I'm gonna quote something that you
wrote in there that I thought was really
interesting because it relates to
something that as you know as economists
maybe this is less true for computer
scientists because they're a little
closer to the UX world were economists
you know we're in this world of rational
optimizing agents blah blah blah he
wrote over the past few years I have
seen startups utilize cash to buy growth
with the goal of optimizing the biggest
top-line possible while neglecting core
elements of their business like user
experience and customer retention a
founders job isn't growth at all costs
growth is the byproduct of an amazing
user experience and and one of the
things that always fascinates me is you
know the history and and and progression
of eBay where you you played an
important role you founded the eBay
Motors site right so do you think that
this is Howie Bey really lost in a way
is that they were growing fast but user
experience was never front and center
okay this is complicated so you guys
follow along and if you want to slip you
know something I actually think that an
optimal user experience is not necessary
for a marketplace I know that's
contrarian and I and I would say that's
not true for every other business model
I can think of liquidity matters Mel's
you know and if you really don't believe
me you know I've got a little you know
an eight-year-old son who's obsessed
with
cars and motorcycles and we're actually
literally today I gotta get back in time
because we have a Craigslist seller
showing up he's looking to buy a vintage
little dirt bike the Craigslist
potentially the worst single popular
website on the planet no app a team
reportedly of 20 to 30 people generating
you know ten figures in income only
monetizing two categories in every
market you can name in every city you
can name user experiences horrible so I
don't mean for marketplace the user
experience has to be ideal its liquidity
but here's what I will say for eBay and
this is what I believe generally and
it's been a long it might seem obvious
to you this has not been obvious to me
is that I actually think the story of
eBay's a stories a lot of companies that
lose their way in that founder centric
businesses Amazon with Bezos today as
opposed to Yahoo without Jerry and Dave
eBay without Pierre day-to-day I think
the founders and it's not some
romanticized version like I'm a pretty
objective guy but I think the difference
if I'm gonna rationalize it is that when
someone takes over business as someone
else built they understand how it works
they don't understand why it works and
there's a big difference so I'm a parent
of two kids my you know I look at them
and when they do something I understand
why because some of it is me like I look
at them like goddamn that's that's an
issue I have and I see it in them and I
and I understand exactly where it comes
from I don't look at what they do all
they do these three things they're for
them like I know I know exactly what's
going on I know the why and I think
professional managers as smart as they
can be anyone who adopts your kid anyone
who takes over a couple will never
understand the why in a in a way that's
intuitive and inmates and also in a way
that a founder cannot explain to someone
else what it means and I I think that is
the core issue and I saw it happening I
was at eBay
the founder was there then wasn't there
and as someone who really spends a lot
of time trying to figure out why things
work I just it's it's been a fascination
of mine everything I like physical
things I like software like this I
really like not how it works that why
they weren't people like I'm really
fascinated by this I tried very hard to
understand and I think I understand it
as well as anyone they didn't actually
you know start it but most people didn't
even understand that wall and I didn't
understand it well enough and I think
that's the reason and I think that's a
common thread through a lot of these
businesses there is no sense of
generational transition if the business
runs out of initial business model
runway there's a line of sight to how
far their business can go with the
initial product with the initial
business model and when you've run to
the end of that and I will argue Tim
Cook is going to face this at Apple you
will and I listen I don't know Tim
that's not my space but I'll say is once
the pipeline dries up once they'll moon
shot things that were started by jobs
once all those things that the founder
understands the market the product the
business gets a deep in in their bones
once that is played out that next wave
that next generation will not do well
they will lean on their market you know
the network effects and they have
network effects with iTunes they're
doing a very smart job of trying to kind
of control the money on the expiry
they do but that all came from jobs
let's be very very clear that's not you
know a brand new thing that is it thing
but that will come to an end at some
point and when it does that next
generation after that will be pretty
weak in my opinion Bezos on the other
hand is just a beast I mean it is
amazing what he's done with Amazon
absolutely amazing and it isn't that
he's brilliant which he probably is it's
he gets it and I think he will but as
long as he is there and fully engaged
that business will be really hard to
compete against it will be a generation
defining company and as soon as he
leaves
it'll take a generation unwind but it
will unwind
it's fascinating because he kind of
answered my second question which I'll
still elaborate on because you know in
economics we think of firms as you know
some production function that fulfills a
role and you know we have these
caricatures of reality and from my own
experience spending two years of ebay in
in the research labs and technology unit
and and then spending a years of VP at
Amazon and seeing the differences in the
way the companies run and as an
economist I hate saying this but it's so
much about more of organizational
behavior and culture than it is about
you know economics or technology and and
the question I wanted to ask is if I
turn the clock back I mean we think of a
based business model right eBay is
Airbnb right eBay is practically every
other one sort of similar to that the
way Craigslist is and nothing came out
of eBay right even even attempts that
you would think where they bought GSI
and they thought they'll do fulfillment
and they sold GSI and you know it has
that right and if the answer really is
well it's because they have the wrong
people and they couldn't see it it's
something that for me as an economist is
a very challenging thing to admit
because it's about the business model
work you should understand there's a
network extra nation to understand it's
about the to site where else could we
employ the two sites at all we could do
it for homes oh we could do it for cars
and that didn't happen and they both
didn't like I did it for cars you did it
for cars right which went from nothing
to 14 billion a year so that was
something but think for Airbnb I
remember when I met Chesky for the first
time and I saw the deck and the cover of
the the presentation said eBay four
spaces and then the company's name was
air bed-and-breakfast or air air bed and
breakfast or something like that and
okay so it was and then underneath and
here's the real trick you don't see
Facebook for something because Facebook
is Facebook for something eBay should
have been eBay for everything right
right for example Facebook when it sees
a competitor it first
clones it and then it actually tries to
buy it in that order it did that to
Instagram event she bought it it did
that to for whatsapp you bought it it
try to buy snapchat and then just clone
the crap out of it and while it's not
amazing it was enough to destabilize
check snapchat there is no facebook for
ephemeral there is no Facebook for you
know like Facebook is Facebook for
everything because Zuckerberg is there
Zuckerberg and he has a lot of control
he bought Instagram and when he bought
it it seems silly
we were actually investors it's a
plug-in Facebook originally and in
Instagram for three days we're investor
Graham we invested it close on Thursday
Zuckerberg was like holy crap I can't
let them get money into that he then
invited the founder Kevin his house and
by Sunday he bought the company for a
billion dollars I think they had I know
a dozen people seventeen people no
revenue numbers that weren't even a
rounding error to a rounding error for
but he looked and goes Jesus these guys
get it he didn't have to go to board a
board would never ever prove that that
was the dumbest financial deal you can
imagine but the smartest strategic move
he could make and he did it if you would
have put a professional manager there
they would have rationalized why that
was stupid why they were small and why
they could do it themselves
he looked at it the market kept the head
was huge he thought the risk was bigger
than the you know rounding error to the
market cap he looked at the guy he's
smart I'm gonna have him I want him on
my team not on the other team there's a
old Lyndon Johnson quote you know the
political quote I'd rather have them
inside the tent pissing out than outside
the tent pissing in and that's a
political context but it also works for
business at some point you'd much much
rather have someone really competitive
and really talented on your team that
you overpaid by two orders of magnitude
then dealing with them for the next
decade just chipping away at you right
brilliant absolutely brilliant only
Zuckerberg would have done that only a
founder would have done that I found him
with control right that's and by the way
he does it over and over again he's gone
from someone which I think there are
questions is he kind of
is age and kind of with his background
able to run what will be one of the
largest companies in history and you see
some moves like that and the answer I
would ask is differently as who else
could do that it's impressive to watch
it really ends by the way I just want to
pass a if things were talking about if
there's like oh well I have a follow-up
please feel free to them okay
so I just want to make that clear in and
some of these questions by the way our
crowdsource from friends and colleagues
that are in this broad space and so is
the Gilded Age so gilded era of new mega
tech firms you know like Fang cafe
whatever we want to call them you know
coming to an end everyone has a
supercomputer in their pocket right or
do we still have more of these companies
you think coming down the horizon I do I
think we have more and in Fortuner
unfortunately barring regulatory
intervention which looks possible the
fang companies will all be trillion plus
dollar companies they'll be multi
trillion dollar companies before they
lose their founder before they lose you
know their network dynamics weaken and
they're all have network dynamics which
are going fascinating with the exception
of Amazon they have purchasing power but
at an extreme you know level I think
we're gonna see some new things so I'm
an investor in a space autonomous
vehicles a lot of people I don't know
it's hard tech and trust me I've had a
very hard time convincing people years
ago when I made these investments today
it seems a little high P but the thing
is imagine instrumenting and networking
all vehicles and maybe even
instrumenting the world we live in
not just tech you know we have the lidar
to interpret the world but having the
world send signals I'm a stop sign I'm a
row like instrumenting the world you
could eliminate 1.1 million deaths but
more importantly you can take one of the
largest industries on the planet
trillion dollar-plus industry and
actually network it and I think those
will create companies that will be worth
hundreds of billions are curling
dollars and so I think we have a few of
those really really big ideas but
ultimately what we really need to do is
the the computer in our pocket is about
networking humanity and I don't think we
fully networked ourselves I mean if you
really really really want to take this
to the logical conclusion we're not
gonna have an external device it'll be
implanted embeddable eventually it'll be
ingrained more genetically you know in
your hardwired into this I know it seems
all odd and science it I mean it seems
weird but let's be clear if I took this
and I went back a hundred years or a
thousand years and told people what it
did they would think there's something
satanic about they would think there's
some sort of weird spiritual religious
it would be terrifying right it'd be
absolutely terrifying I think the same
way we view biology and computer science
merging is absolutely terrifying in many
ways I think maybe an affront to you
know a lot of religious beliefs but I
think the ultimate networking is not
this external device but truly
networking humanity and think about the
possibilities were instantaneously real
time no language barrier no latency for
timing and being like it's a make and
then making it so it's deeply embedded
in how we think and how we it's crazy
it's amazing and terrifying at the same
time and I think that's the ultimate if
you think of the penultimate or the
defining network that can be built it is
networking all of you man and we're
getting there this is a very good
stutter step to that yeah okay so you
mentioned one word that a lot of people
at least in my space have very opposing
views on and that's the R word
regulation and and I'm wondering what
you believe I mean the risk is clearly
there because we see what's happening
globally and and populism doesn't help
with that what do you think the risks
currently are for both the fang Gaffa
firms and others both in terms of
regulation motivated by pseudo economic
thinking like oh these are essential
facilities
and then of course the regulation that's
more motivated by unfairness and listen
I'm yeah I've always tried to define
myself politically and I think I'd be a
lowercase L libertarian I think but my
point is I think this is not gonna be an
economic argument it's gonna be a
political argument and I think that's a
wrong domain to have this argument and
I've much much much rather err on the
side of being much more open and letting
people you know and companies do what
they want to do and then later kind of
reactively kind of clean up some mess
behind and I'll give you an example so I
go through this thought exercise every
time I do regulatory something there's
been a lot of time thinking about this
because ultimately in in my world and if
everyone here is in platform world in
his near world - is that everything that
actually creates a innovative platform
that connects supply and demand this
intermediates everything in between all
the steps in between and by definition
that revolutionizing the supply chain
actually is is is in a head-on collision
course with regulation you cannot
fundamentally change that and not
disrupt incumbents in a very material
way so I think every marketplace of
notes and I mean everyone is going to
face a regulatory pressure by definition
they the way I look at it I don't look
at it as bad thing your idea is not that
big if you don't face regulatory
pressure right I don't even want to
invest a lot of in companies company
like hey here's the risk page you know
they put on the risk on there they say
we have regulatory pressure and I'm like
great and then they're like they usually
get stuck on that page with it an
investor so what's going down the a b5
and what do you think and my thing is
like if you didn't have that I actually
would not be that interested your idea
is pretty small but because of that you
have to deal with this and my worry is
that the right thing to do is to allow
this to happen in the example I give is
the thought exercises referencing is I
go back and look at the dawn of the
internet so you go back you can read
about it the very dawn Bill Clinton was
president there was an enormous Porsche
- Under
stand the internet and its impact into
taxon right which is not completely
unfair there's some questions about
Nexus so in eBay we had this big
question if you have the companies
headquartered in the Bay Area you have a
seller rural New York in a buyer in
Alabama where's the Nexus in the
transaction where is it what gets taxed
I don't know no one knew right but the
issue was not unfair to think like
someone's got to be taxed right you
can't buy and sell stuff and not be
taxed and what Bill Clinton did which
was I think I look back and like I think
a little bit heroic at the time now it
looks like it was an obvious decision
they said we're just gonna have a
moratorium we're just not going to think
about it let it play out
it's an infancy we don't even know what
we don't know it kind of is impressive
it's working America owns this let's
just kind of get out of its whele and
then eventually we'll figure it out
I have no doubt the government will take
a step in and we'll figure it out which
is happened what just happened right now
a lot longer than people expected it
took a generation my thing is with
autonomy with commerce with you know now
the labor force right and you're looking
W to versus 1099 I don't understand why
we lead with regulation instead of lag
with regulation if you lead with
regulation you will suffocate
potentially in industry and the world is
very very efficient it'll just happen
somewhere else
if anyone believes that by regulating
these big companies you end
human-interest for connection or you
somehow lessen net that they know
they're kind of the laws of physics for
network effects or somehow you change
anything you're wrong all you're gonna
change is the home where that actually
is headquartered that's it that's all
that's gonna change and so my worry is a
political decision where you have very
true this income inequality which is
unsustainable long term making a
strategic or financial decision based on
politics does not end well in my real
worry is that the u.s. GDP will be
impacted if you want to do another
thought exercise where would the
American economy
today if we lost quote lost the internet
what if Facebook was based in France and
Amazon was based in Germany and Google
were based in Italy go through the
exercise and ask yourself what what
would we be talking our income in you
know inequality would be a small issue
compared to the entire economy
decelerating where we're no longer we're
in this perpetual recession where we're
having a very hard time not like we're
contracting right all the pains we feel
would be magnified right and I think
that's what we're talking about I really
do I think this is of national security
interest in many ways beyond economics I
think the politics will be terrifying
one generation from now if we do this I
do I do and I know it's alarmist and I'm
a business guy I get all that but I'm
actually legitimately scared well I
think the evidence that works in favor
of your conjecture is you know look at
where all these businesses are and look
at Europe that is much heavier regulated
I had a lot more constraints and
businesses are just not popping up there
that is not an accident idea this
American exceptionalism which I get it
and there's there's case for that but
the idea that we're so creative and
we're so amazing misses the point that
structurally if you have the right
structure and you have creative and all
that then it will blossom right it's
like a plan you need sunlight and water
and healthy soil like you it's not one
element and the structure here has been
fantastic the issue is that structure
may not stay that way and I'm terrified
when I read about the break-up first of
all I don't even know what breaking up a
book from if you're talking about a
platform I think about this as well you
take a platform which in many ways these
horizontal rigid singular monolithic
platform where do you break them I don't
even know where you break them what your
search is saying is destroy them let
them but there is no there's no nice
little piece like sure can you get rid
of Instagram that's all but Instagram
isn't Facebook what do you do to
Facebook are you you break up like what
is breaking up Facebook
right it essentially means ending
Facebook right or selling marginal
pieces which ultimately don't really
matter like you know whether you can
split from Amazon AWS great your splint
AWS it doesn't make any difference
Amazon will still be a juggernaut
rolling over every small independent
business it will enclosures of malls
that is now inevitable unless you end
Amazon but if you do then it will be
someone else and you'll still lose all
those businesses accept all those jobs
and economic you know benefits will
accrue to another country it's it feels
crazy to watch it I don't even know how
this is an actual debate let me be clear
I think government and technology have
to work as partners now if you really
want the right questions why isn't it
happening and I'll give you my theory I
you know I have a you know I spent a lot
of time in rooms with government folks
and I think I endured well I've
rationalized my own mind why it's not
working
here's the thing is I think you lagged
not lead so you need to understand what
the issues are first and second you
focus on safety in order to protect
people not in order to redistribute or
somehow change the economics Facebook is
profitable and it should stay pro like
there's nothing wrong with that
Facebook also has not protected the
public that there is something wrong
with that but the idea that somehow
Facebook is too big is I think the wrong
framing it is not its size and its
profitability which people resent I
think it's the fact that it was
indifferent to its impact on society on
the way to making money but the fact it
makes money isn't the issue the fact
they need some sort of and I think it's
fine they could have been imposed with
this therfore if they're doing this
editorial body and if you saw we're
gonna have this external body they'll be
able to make independent decisions
outside of the company and essentially
they're gonna regulate themselves and
you can make a very fair case the
Facebook shouldn't be creating that body
that would not be fair that the
government that's not unfair right
that's not unfair and what you should
look at is how do you protect and save
the government's job is to protect
people the government's job is not to
take money for in my view to take money
from businesses that are working to
destroy them in order say either the
money's going to go to someone else or
there'll be no money to be made that
just feels like the wrong it just feels
like the wrong line but there is a place
or safety let's be very clear and I do
think if there are monopolistic or
certain anti-competitive behaviors there
aren't there are measures and there are
things we should do but this is nothing
debate we're having the breaking up
these big companies essentially the way
I understand and I've been listening
carefully is society's unequal and that
is true and it is unfair and you can you
can look at the numbers any way you want
but you really have to distort them
beyond belief to not see what's going on
but just you know it's just true right
there's no the middle class is being
hollowed out right you're becoming their
haves and have-nots and in history has
not been kind to that's social structure
at all that is led to every major war
it's like it's bad so even if you don't
even if you like it it's unsustainable
but but the thing is when you when you
look at that that the the role of
government isn't to kind of rectify that
that is a different thing is to create a
structure where people have ability and
to protect people make things safe so I
I just think the line is is the wrong
place
I I find that small and probably
irrelevant in the big picture of I think
tech is is a more meaningful thing than
a utility that was aggravating and was
no longer pricing fairly and no you're
wrong it in many ways it was unfair I
think it's in material I'm I look back
now and you guys may be the impact is
bigger than I I fully appreciate when I
read about that it didn't sound like
society was started it felt like people
are gonna overpay and that's bad but
that's not horrible what we're talking
about now I think is significantly worse
I actually think we have our society so
imbalance in the world is seeing this
with populism and nationalism and holy
crap is that if we don't do something
and there's a political issue and
there's some economic issues there will
be a price to be paid and this looks a
lot like what all major Wars the period
the error that precedes them we look
exactly like that and I know no one
likes to say this looks a hell of a lot
like pre-world War two like it's
terrifying
right but the government forcing and
taking control I think exists I think it
makes it worse and if you want to kind
of think through it imagine this
administration having full a lot more
control over that is that good or bad
and the question would be why would any
future administration be better I'm not
sure the answer is more centralization
I'm really not trying to cop you and
then maybe as an investor what do you
think about investing somebody like well
to your point most investors who focused
on social as their thing and I know some
are no longer investing or they switch
their focus investing in social networks
and their Facebook is a bad career
decision it is now you could your
question which i think is what it's
leading to is is that the right place to
be in or not
it may not be ideal but the question I
think you have to ask yourself is is the
right answer to break it up and hit the
reset button go now all have at it you
just can get the next Facebook right and
it's just gonna happen
all over again because now you've
created the the vacuum right like
someone's gonna fill that and these
businesses have network dynamics become
dominant and the question of society we
should say should there be no dominant
companies if that's the case we're gonna
have no platforms none right and I'm not
sure the platform is at fault and let's
be clear platforms do topple eventually
they all weekend and you could have made
on the margins that Facebook can not by
serious competitors I think that's
actually pretty fair Instagram I
remember when Kevin came and he
presented to you know our partnership
and I didn't ask him any questions the
numbers were impressed he's super
impresses but I did ask one question
raised my hand I said how can you
survive in a world where your core
business is sharing photos and if I were
being a very cynical guy I'd say
Facebook is a photo sharing app with a
thin layer communication you are can be
like and how how do you compete with
them how do you know and I asked them
and I got the kind of answer smart
people give you which is you know it's
different whatever but ultimately he was
gonna be on a collision course he was
either gonna have to be able to take on
a Facebook or get bought by Facebook or
get crushed by Facebook and if they if
Facebook weren't able to buy it
I think Instagram today would be a fifty
two hundred billion dollar company would
it be a trillion dollar company probably
not would it be real it would be now it
wouldn't be as big as it is today
its its size today because of Facebook
but it still would be material and I
think on the margins you can do that
maybe you have rules where you're not
allowed to buy any adjacent business if
you're a network or maybe any company I
think that's fair maybe you're allowed
to buy geographic competitors if you're
weak so you could buy a German Facebook
if Germany had a Facebook or like uber
can buy DV like but you can't buy lyft
or you can't buy convoy which is uber
for Freight which is one of my
businesses or you can't buy
uber eat which would be maybe door - so
no adjacency in your dominant markets
you can buy Geographic no Jason C but
you can buy core Geographic that doesn't
feel stupid right that's fair but
breaking up the company seems nutty I
think yes looking forward and what new
things could come up what do you think
is the place to be n is there any part
of well if you guys know the next place
tell me I'd love to know and that'd be
awesome I can tell you where I'm I've
invested recently so like I said I've
done autonomy and I think there'll be
some great networks built around that
bits hard tech and networks and it's
really complicated I've made a couple of
big bets make a so so I believe in that
I'm putting my money where my mouth is I
believe in b2b marketplaces I did convoy
five years ago almost five and it's
doing really really really well it's
great it's it's doing great I think it's
gonna be a meaningful company and the
reason I'm looking at b2b and I'd even
put FinTech there is that the obvious
consumer facing marketplace is that you
can be your own consumer for that are
straightforward I think they're they're
vertical izing I know you you know I
kind of you know what back for it like I
think the horizontal plays are mostly
played out for the tech stacks that we
have and they kind of and what's
happening is are starting to get narrow
and deep goats for shoes I didn't buy
these there but I bought I buy a bunch
of heart to get gym shoes on goat it's
great it's kind of a Jewish shoe
marketplace right they're getting narrow
so if you want bigness right now without
any new distribution platform without
any new technology stack I think you
have to look at b2b and I think FinTech
mostly because they're very
sophisticated and they're not easy to do
b2b many cases were unsexy I remember
when I met the guys doing convoy I've
been looking for a trucking marketplace
and I've talked to you I like
transportation it's a space I like and I
like the fact they loved it and we had
that conversation you know
it's the head of data science was here
for the last three days I had to go back
today he's great yeah yeah you know and
Dan and grant are fantastic but it was
an unsexy space that was not well
understood
TRUCKING is not you go through Stanford
and Berkeley you go through trust me
you're gonna understand very little
about trucking and you're gonna want
some though it even less right um so I
think finding blind spots that are
complex as financial services as a
unaddressed and kind of overlooked as
trucking and I think you have to find
those pockets to find these big
horizontal planes and that's I look at
them but I only look at the ones I find
personally interesting I'm not going to
spend the next ten years of my life you
know on some weird you know esoteric boy
like that's just not what I want to do
you know but those are what I would look
for the next thing when the distribution
channels change there's a next
generation of distribution channel
there's a next generation of Technology
and I think AV is next generation there
then I actually all son there's a whole
bunch of new opportunities I want to go
back to the government and and company
interaction another article that you
wrote that I enjoyed very much is the
one where you I don't know if you coined
the term but I thought it was pretty
cool I'm Collard worker I tried I try to
make it a thing no one I don't wanna dog
I think I may be the only other persons
are presented I tried coining that I'm
colored workers they're blue-collar
they're white collar on collar basically
the online thing the gig workers I never
I didn't coin game so so you know you
wrote this in 2015 and now it's just
becoming a real topic of conversation
there's a whole issue of you know health
care and wages and everything that goes
with it and of course in the United
States we have a problem that by and
large private health care because we
don't have a one pace system we could
that's a whole different argument don't
want to go there but it usually goes
together with the workplace right so you
know a double risk I could lose my job
and my own there right so so there there
are two things I'm wondering about your
thoughts about one is is there a path
towards a healthier discussion
where government will provide the kind
of regulation infrastructures and other
inputs into a world that will be more
accommodating for this where in some
countries like Canada maybe or
Scandinavia it's much less of a problem
because in health care and and the
second question is should we be concerns
concern about at the end platform
sucking up the surplus so that these
uncolored workers are basically minimum
paid employees so two issues let's
separate them yeah our first issue is
that you know it's something I care
about and I've thought about for years
now which is what is how did the
regulatory impacts affect people right
because ultimately the regulatory stuff
can be who makes money who doesn't yeah
but you're talking about livelihood for
people and so my view is that the gig
workers there is a generation and now it
seems obvious although we'll see if if
it happens your plays up but that people
will not be working for monolith in
companies that many people will be
working for multi multiple platforms
right and we can talk about why that's
true and and I just think the era of
these these singular these singular
corporations offering a singular surface
will give way to these distributed
networks millions of people offering a
combined or collaborative service right
and I think I think we're gonna see this
decentralization it's more efficient
there's a whole host of reasons why
that's gonna exist but it does beg the
question what do you do with workers and
right now we have two classes of workers
your w-2 or 1099 right your independent
contractor you're actually a full-time
employee and with full-time employment
comes benefits without you know for 1099
no benefits no training I mean it's it's
terrible but you have control so right
now you have a world I have control but
no security and stability i stability
but no control i think the world needs a
third class of workers and what i've
written about is a dependence
contractor where you would have the
benefits of both you determine I want to
work for uber I want to work for wag
this afternoon whenever you decouple the
benefits from your employment and then
whatever hours you work may be pro rata
they would pay for it if there isn't a
single payor for the government and that
they would share the burden of that and
they can train you all they want to
train you so you decide what you do when
you do it you have stability of some pro
rata prorated health care benefits while
if it is you know but it's decoupled
from any one corporation and you create
that class I thought it seemed
reasonable so I got I've written a bit
about the stuff the Obama administration
reached out to me I was and asked me to
come in for this like conference singer
yes I'll go sure went there it was an
interesting experience but when I was in
there I met a lot of breakout sessions
and I was asked to speak at a couple of
them so I went to one of them and it
took him about 10 seconds to realize you
know I was there as an invited guest to
be the token capitalist or token venture
guide my first session I was in holy
crap i sat there and I was yelled at and
I mean literally yelled at by a
questioner he wasn't even asking a
question he was ranting and screaming at
me and he was the head of some union
thing and I like there wasn't you know
and so I try to answer and I say listen
I think this is good for workers I think
having control I grew up lower middle
class and I think what is the only thing
worse than not having money is not
having control and I think people who
are wealthy actually assume your default
state is control and that you're just
trying to optimize for more capital
right more cash and that's really not
the case usually you don't have cash or
control if you're if you're poor and if
you had to make a trade off many people
who take control over cash right they've
learned how to live without cash but
it's hard to learn and so I'm trying to
explain that I'm trying very hard to
explain that it's it's horrible and so
by the end of the experience what I
realized is the Democrats and and I
identify as a Democrat so you know
I'm not trying to bash it but the
Democrats were framing the issue as
pro-worker means you're Pro w2
anti-worker
your actually wants these ubers and
lyft's to be 1099 and that framing is
politically expedient it works it
freakin works and I told my guys when I
got back I called up all my guys in
marketplaces and said you need to give
me a plan before our next board meeting
how you're gonna turn every worker
eventually to w2 because we can't this
is gonna crap I said I'm not saying
today I said I'm convinced there's zero
percent chance that this is not
eventually gonna happen it could be
years it's going to happen and you need
a plan
and I did I had every one of my
companies and it looks now like we're
seeing it with a b5 it's gonna happen I
think it's a mistake I think the right
answer is to recognize the workforce has
shifted create a class of workers that
represents the current status of the
workforce and then again not predicting
who does healthcare who knows how that's
all going to play out but actually make
it so that the classification of work is
something that feels progressives load
word but but feels relevant to today's
workforce but I do not believe that's
gonna happen at all as a matter of fact
if I'm a betting guy I can't bet for a
living I bet that is not gonna happen
near to midterm but if I also were gonna
bet long-term someone gives me a
generational bent over generation I
think it is inevitable that the worker
classification will eventually resemble
the workforce it will be a painful there
will be a 20 year period I think me
exceed anything and what do you think
about the concern that you know once
we're living in that space sooner or
later and that platforms will be able to
extract a lot of the value generated and
that well you know it might even
exacerbate that I hear yes tribution is
sales tribution I hear I hear it but I
think possible problems do not equal
definite problems so here's what's
happening the the platform's actually
unlock a lot of rents distributed assets
uber doesn't have to buy vehicles you
use your own vehicle
that's highly efficient capacity
utilization Amer is a holy [ __ ] that's a
lot more efficient than if you bought
them and actually had limited
utilization you density centralized
workforce so the workforce doesn't have
to work full-time they can work and they
can scale up or scale down like it's
very dynamic and very decentralized it's
really efficient so and you don't have
to house two million people you don't
have to have buildings you have to worry
about laying people off like holy [ __ ]
like it's amazing so those rents get
unlocked and that's a good thing the
question is there's three main
constituents it goes to either the
company and the company can keep it in
margin or pass it on and dividends or
whatever but the company gets it it
gives it to the customer and lower
prices right it gives it to the service
rider in this case the driver or the
host whatever and kind of higher higher
take they give them a bigger piece of it
so the real question isn't should we
somehow reduce the ability for companies
to unlock more rents efficiency and
productivity is inevitable and desirable
the question is how does it get split
and I have my own theory of how it ends
up getting split but I don't think it's
as easy saying if the companies unlock
it the companies will keep it so I'll
give you an example
I think these these platforms need to
have a higher degree of transparency and
to instrument and measure everything for
example if you have a host that's
unusually good you as a platform Airbnb
should pay them more why isn't there a
VIP level because the service is
fantastic because if they left that
would hurt you right or if you're a
driver who was productive or how my
thing is if you make it or if you have
some competition you like you need to
create the the environments where the
the money these extra rents go where
they belong and I agree without any pull
anywhere else the companies will keep it
all I'm saying is you we should create
some pool
we really should and if you're looking
with the the the uber and lyft has its
own dynamic which is actually beneficial
to all the participants there they would
not be paying people as much as they're
paying them
they just wouldn't and you can argue
they're not being paid enough trust me
they be paid less that goober was a
monopoly so I think the right thing is
to try to find that tension and with
that tension I think it'll get kind of
rationed but without that tension I
think the company is wandering at all of
it and by the way historically that's
what's happened always so think about it
you do a price increase or you somehow
have a productivity gain in a company
where does that money go shareholders
the company the shareholders right so I
but I do think there's some role for
third parties help create some tension
there you know we're out of time I just
want to see if there's maybe one or two
more questions asset light things has it
free not even asset lights let's be
clear truly I mean they didn't take the
loans on their own sheet and then you
know so far some of the other the way
that thing is evolved they're taking on
a table yeah well then a there's three
distinguish one is you take in your own
balance sheet your bank you can call it
to your financial institution you are
right but financial institutions do that
and by the way let's be clear you don't
produce the money you're buying the
money from there so the end of that
you're still banker or financial
institution in might and I think
technically you would be one too but but
practical you are even if technically or
not the second one is you barman it'd be
like we work or we company or whatever
they don't own the buildings they lease
them they're not a frickin marketplace i
I'm shocked like why are people calling
them a tech company right that's how the
lending thing is but if you go the third
step which is where it is a marketplace
imagine people real people lending their
money to other real people right and
they stop doing cuz the leverage wasn't
great that's a marketplace in my opinion
the second one where you borrow money
and then you just sell the money you
know resell the money with a markup
makes you some sort of quasi financial
thing
then if you actually have in our balance
sheet I think you are clearly a
financial institution doesn't matter
does not matter in my view is it isn't
the length of time and I've even argued
isn't this size it's the fact that you
are a principal a marketplace or
platform is not a principal there is no
financial risk none none and all this
stuff we work has enormous financial
risk if you look at we work we work as
essentially if you think they're buying
30 or 30-year commitments and they're
selling it in 30 day increments is
buying a newspaper and selling you the
sports section right like it's it's not
a tray like I don't get if we work feels
more like a financial company than it
feels a tech of it's crazy I don't even
like really state finance it's realistic
it's not even a close call it's weird
how people are like it's a tech company
it's nutty but what you're talking about
there's three buckets and I think people
into it seems confusing but it is you're
not a principal here's another way to
think about I think about imagine this
physical room a school right or physical
if you own the room and you set the
rules who is allowed to come in who's
allowed to go out based on some very
fair open rules you're the venue you're
the location I'm not a principal
whatever's going on in here you could
hold an auction in here buying and
selling stuff I'm indifferent I just get
a piece of what happens and then make
sure the room is safe people are vetted
the lights are on the actual place is
not a principal in the transaction the
only way your principals transaction you
get it take and you bring it take
because you met you match the point
demand and you're in a trusted
environment but your take is not a it's
not even being a proxy for a principal
it happens to be a byproduct is its
easiest way to charge you could charge
just for room rent you could just say if
you're on my platform under charge you
per month turns out that's not it
doesn't align incentives but it's it's a
head-fake
if there is no principal interaction it
is you're not if that makes sense
gotta get completely out in that that's
it let's be clear I don't define having
written a book on it it's not much
it is my definition of what a platform
is right technical issues but it's still
still related to of the division of
surplus so there's all claims here and
statements that you know Pleasant okay
called a surplus and then now they're
two sides well we'll be left with little
but Eve the setting isn't somewhat
competitive then that's how the
questionable in the United lift you know
they're losing billions of dollars a
year so in fact my question is the
opposite in a setting where Monica's a
fairly competitive or another example of
it ended up work where you know it's
that's crabber there's other other
things where you really can't think much
of a cupcake as a platform you generate
a lot of failure but what other than
just straight-up Commission which may
work in some cases but the mean others
may not because of competition what are
the other good ways of monetizing well
functioning platform the platform itself
is not genuine generates valuable so two
things let's see the first the first is
I agree with you with the rent
I do not fundamentally believe that the
platform's will absorb all the rents up
let's play this out let's assume one
assumption that there is a gig economy
there's a lot of worker there semi
skilled to unskilled certain platforms
are going to want the most skilled of
them and they're the ones that create
the most value and there's most economic
right they've unlocked the rents the
most mo they're now fighting for growth
with one a dog walker versus a host
versus a driver versus whatever right
they're gonna go we unlock X dollars of
value per hour we want your hour and
you're gonna say gringo but we want the
best the service-oriented the most
reliable who can live up to an SLA
whatever it is and they go we don't want
you to spend an incremental our dog
walking we're gonna pay you more you're
gonna find they're gonna take part of
the unlock rents are gonna like there
will be an equilibrium because remember
it's not just being a dominant player in
one space you know
competing with every other incremental
gig our and who has a highest marginal
value per hour that's what you're really
doing and the people who have unlocked
the most are gonna pay the mouse to get
the best and then the dog walker is
going to be the least reliable and the
least skilled it will be the most
unskilled and that will mean 15 bucks an
hour and this will be 30 an hour and the
30 an hour is high relative and
eventually they might have to paint
subsidize your insurance because I can't
only get people it's like it will as
long as you believe there is a stratum
of this type of work and it is big
there'll be some competitive balance and
maybe not enough to make it fair and
that's that but the idea that it's all
gonna go only works in my view is if the
platform has all the control meaning
it's a monopoly and there's only one
industry that has gig workers and the
unemployment rate in the nation is high
well that's possible but how likely is
that we live in an exact opposite world
right now gig economy is exploding the
unemployment rate is low they're all
fighting there's min effect uber and
lyft spent five ten thousand dollars
getting one driver it's unprecedented
right so so that's the second is how do
you align that I do think that the the
hourly rate will give way I think if
there's enough competitive pressure and
enough economics that are unlocked we're
gonna see what happened if you look at
labor over generations I've started
reading some of this stuff and I need to
read more you may enter but if you look
at like how benefits you know pension
benefits defined benefits not to find
contribution defined benefits they came
as a concession post-world war an idea
was they didn't want to give more wages
they thought it'd be cheaper cuz people
worked and then they died right but like
oh I'm gonna give you well true now that
wasn't such a small concession that the
demographic joke is on the companies
like they now are drowning in this you
just enormous burden but the thing is
companies will be creative and give you
things the ARB is you may not take the
shape I think ultimately what's gonna
happen if I'm a betting guy in a world
where this is moderately too heavily
competitive so not modestly to lightly
competitive what's going to happen is
one there can get equity because you're
gonna because it's free to give and for
some of these companies like uber it's
gonna be life life-changing to I think
ultimately training benefits ancillary
stuff where there's scale benefits for
the business because they can they can
create their own insurance pool they can
actually insure your vehicles they could
purchase the vehicles and sell them to
you it cost if there's a way that the
company can actually get an ARB where
it's something was worth more to you
than it costs of them I think you're
gonna start seeing some of that and
those will be meaningful I think by the
way I think housing will end up happen
here for workers you know like you look
back everything in a ghost will circle
the grinev company towns like I think
you're gonna see benefits that come to
workers to distinguish companies in ways
that are not just in an hourly salary
and I think that's inevitable but what
I'd love to see the right right answer
if it's super competitive is equity and
a piece of the principle meaning a piece
of the actual pot I don't think that
will happen unless it's really
competitive but I'm not convinced that's
not gonna be the case I think a lot of
people are convinced somehow I'm not
convinced that we're not going to be
pricing the gig workers at the high end
at 30 to 50 bucks per hour I think
that's very all-in I think that's fully
possible
okay well let's all thank Simon for his
time it says and I want to thank
everyone who came and participated in
the conference and hopefully we'll do
something similar in five years I don't
know
[Laughter]
[Applause]